but on that are saying part on the loom
who me on a normal day I said to Diallo
tells us she'd be at her fam in the
village of EUR GU her children looking
after the livestock but instead they're
in a camp for displaced people more than
a hundred kilometers from home alongside
many other Buki Nabi who have fled
attacks villagers arrived in January
after many were killed in a revenge
attack when a rival community blamed
them for the murder of a local chief and
his sons they burnt our houses and
clothes i fled with six children they
accused us of collaborating with the
armed groups from outside the country
this is what remains of their village
following other attacks more than 200
thousand people have fled from their
homes in parts of the north and east
over the last three years some blame
armed groups in Burkina Faso as well as
others from neighbouring Mali for the
increasing violence and tensions between
rival communities are making the crisis
harder to resolve the wild food program
says it's a humanitarian emergency
more than a million people need help we
are focus working just in the area which
is much more safe so we are not for the
tabie going where it is supposed to be
security problem it's really hard to
imagine the horror some of these
displaced people have faced most of them
have come here with nothing but the
clothes they're wearing they're supposed
to start harvesting their crops soon but
those we talked to said they can't go
back to their villages to do that
because it's still too dangerous
sourdough go quest window and a few
others however did manage to return to
their village after government forces
secured the area
he still relies on food aid hidden I
have 20 family members to feed my three
wives children and grandchildren this
food will last for two weeks we fled
from our home before we could plant
because the neighbouring diplo village
was attacked and we feared attackers
would come to our homes next after a
whole day's wait so a dog who starts his
long journey back home it's fifty
kilometers away and he'll pass through a
dangerous area but he says it's a risk
he's willing to take to feed his family
clattering sorry al Jazeera nothing Buki
no Faso